[Musique]
michel vialay bonjour bonjour bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro du café politique
à les y installer vous on va évidemment
revenir sur votre parcours personnel
votre parcours politique
on vous connaît finalement assez peu ici
à saint quentin en yvelines puisque vous
êtes un élu du mantois vous avez fait
toute votre carrière toute votre vie
dans le dans le mantois est-ce que tout
de même ça vous parle saint quentin en
yvelines
excusez-moi la métaphore sportive vous
ne jouez pas domicile ici est ce que ça
vous parle quand même oui vous savez
saint quentin en yvelines c'est pas si
éloigné que cela de mantes-la-jolie et
le même département
ces mêmes départements d'abord et puis
il ya beaucoup de mental qui viennent y
travailler puisque ici il ya un bassin
d'emploi extrêmement important donc oui
ça me parle je parlais je faisais la
métaphore physique puisque sportif
plutôt puisque vous êtes un ancien
sportif alors je sais pas si vous êtes
un ancien sportif ou si vous êtes encore
sportifs actuels vous avez pratiqué
pendant longtemps le basket vous avez
été président d'un club de basket est ce
que vous avez encore le temps de faire
du sport avec votre activité politique
1 je vois que vous êtes bien renseigné
moi j'ai juste été sur votre site
internet un pas plus à coeur oui
effectivement j'ai joué au basket
pendant pendant de nombreuses années
j'ai commencé je devais avoir 10 ans et
j'ai arrêté lorsque j'en avais à peu
près 45 parce que des problèmes aux
genoux
pas très original pour un basketteur ont
fait qu'on m'a conseillé d'avoir des
sports beaucoup plus doux pour les
articulations
mais effectivement j'ai présidé en même
temps le
le club de basket de mantes la jolie qui
est un club qui monte jusqu'au plus haut
niveau régional donc je ne sais pas si
vous êtes basketteur mais pour ce qu'ils
prennent juste trop petit non pas
forcément vous auriez fait un bon meneur
de jeu voilà je vous avais l'air alerte
avant la politique vous avez eu un
engagement aussi une carrière dans le
privé vous avez commencé à travailler à
18 ans ce que ça veut dire que les
études c'était pas forcément votre truc
à vous non c'est pas ça du tout c'est
que pour des raisons tout à fait
personnelles j'ai décidé que c'était
bien que je puisse m'installer
que je puisse prendre me prendre mon
envol comme on dit l'engagement
politique est arrivé un autre plus tard
beaucoup plus tard vers vos 35 ans
pourquoi vous avez décidé à un moment de
vous engager de devenir maire-adjoint à
à mantes la jolie s'était alors en 1995
et si mes informations sont bonnes elles
sont très bonnes
écoutez vous comme vous l'avez souligné
j'ai été président du club de basket
aussi
et à cette occasion g
bien vu que le bénévolat était quelque
chose qui était de plus en plus
difficiles à mobiliser et une des
solutions qui pouvait être importantes
pour pouvoir bien faire fonctionner le
club était de mutualiser un certain
nombre de moyens pour aller jusqu'à la
fusion avec le club voisin le kreul le
club riverains de mantes-la-ville ce que
jamais facile parce que lorsqu'on est
d'un côté à l'autre de la voie ferrée il
ya quand même une certaine logique de
derby qui peut qui a pu s'installer en
local au fil des années bien sûr et nous
avons commencé pour voir s'il aventure
pouvait pouvaient être positives à se
dire que l'on gagnerait à ce que les
meilleurs éléments masculins viennent
jouer la menthe avec les meilleurs
éléments féminins viennent jouer à
mantes la ville est alors que nous
avions à nos yeux surmonter le plus
difficile c'est à dire de rapprocher
d'abord les sportives de convenir de ce
qu'allait être la gouvernance d'aller
convaincre deux présidents de clubs
ce ne sont que les politiques qui
étaient là qui nous ont dit vous avez le
droit de fille lucia fusionner et bien
évidemment on ne peut pas vous en
empêcher
on sait bien association 1901 oblige par
contre pour l'attribution des créneaux
et pour les subventions alors ça vous
passerez vraiment en dernier et encore
engagement en politique du coup en 1995
est devenu à ce que ça ça m'a permis
justement de prendre conscience qu'il
fallait passer à l'échelon d'une suite
pour faire avancer les choses
vous êtes devenu maire de
mantes-la-jolie en 2005 vous êtes resté
12 en mer aujourd'hui vous êtes député
serait-ce que 13 à 15 reste est presque
est ce que c'est ce que ça vous manque
l'échelon local est ce que vous
regrettez vivement de ne pas pouvoir
cumuler ou alors finalement vous
comprenez dans cette société moderne
démocratique on ne puisse plus cumuler
comme avant alors je trouve d'abord que
cette loi qui est passé sous le
gouvernement allende est une voie qui
est tout à fait stupide et les stupides
parce que il n'y a aucune logique à ce
qu'un parlementaire soit 100 soit coupée
de son territoire
c'est la volonté a été de 2,2 hollande
macron va exactement dans le
dans le même sens rien ne vous empêche
en tant que député de venir à nantes un
peut de toute façon je suis resté
conseiller municipal oui c'est vrai ça
c'est pas interdit est bien sûr je
m'implique sur mantes la jolie
comme dans l'ensemble de la
circonscription mais je pense que avoir
ce cumul des mandats n'est pas une
difficulté en tant que tel au contraire
ça pouvait avoir des intérêts enfin
toujours les avoirs j'ai toujours milité
et travailler pour le mantois
mais c'est vrai que des fois c'est
intéressant d'avoir plusieurs levées
levier pour pouvoir faire avancer les
sujets faire avancer les dossiers
alors hier mans aussi cette loi
n'existait pas j'aurais fait comme
beaucoup de mes prédécesseurs et jaurès
des mers bien vous avez succédé à
l'époque à pierre bédier permet dit que
vous avez aussi côtoyé au conseil
départemental de 2009 à 2013
on connaît le poids politique de pierre
bédier dans le département quel est
votre rapport à lui quel est votre
rapport à lui à pierre bédier est ce que
c'est un peu votre mentor politique est
ce que c'est un exemple pour vous pierre
bédier et j'ai de très bons rapports
avec pierre bédier en tout bien tout
honneur bien évidemment je pense que
c'est lui qui m'a conduit à m'engager en
politique parce que je reviens un tout
petit peu en arrière quand je vous
disais j'ai pris conscience qu'il
fallait passer à l'échelon supérieur et
s'investir en politique
encore fallait-il savoir dans quel cadre
avec qui pour quoi faire
c'est d'une rencontre que j'ai pu avoir
avec lui avant qu'il ne s'engage même
pour pour la colère la commune parce
qu'ils étaient préalablement conseiller
général des ja et conseiller régional
ces deux rencontres avec lui que cet
homme m'a convaincu de tout ce que l'on
pouvait faire en politique d'autre que
j'avais vu dans le passé n'avaient pas
eu la même force et de conviction et
surtout le même intérêt donc j'ai deux
j'ai de très bons rapports de très bons
rapports avec calais et nous les noirs
fois aussi puisque lui a été secrétaire
d'état est ce qui vous donner des
conseils il connaît le plus haut niveau
de l'état est ce que vous donnez des
conseils en tant que député ou alors
vous avez passé ce niveau là avec lui
des conseils nous avons nous avons dès
que s'il a des conseils à donner je les
prends des fois je peux lui donner
quelques conseils aux sociétés
actuellement sur la sur la forme mais
sur les informations que je peux avoir
au partage un grand nombre de sujets
depuis de nombreuses années le
fonctionnement
comment dire il n'y a pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre nous
votre engagement politique s'est
toujours fait à droite depuis 1995 est
ce que la droite c'est une histoire de
famille chez vous est ce que c'est
plutôt des convictions personnelles
quelle était votre rapport aussi
familial entre la famille et la
politique est ce que c'était un sujet
dont vous parliez ce que vos parents
étaient engagés politiquement
mes parents n'étaient pas engagés
politiquement sportivement oui mon père
a été membre fondateur de l'association
sportive nantaise vous savez ce grand
club de 4500 membres qui couvre 35
section je fais un petit peu de raison
même s'il ya le vélodrome qui était
juste en face mais on ne parlait pas
beaucoup politique le
à la maison l'engagement à droite c'est
pas parce que c'est la droite ou que
c'est la gauche c'est surtout autour des
idées des projets qui pouvaient être
portées également localement mais
nationalement j'ai toujours trouvé que
ma sensibilité s'inscrivait beaucoup
plus dans tout ce qui a été portée
notamment par les présidents chirac
j'allais dire justement vous avez vu
votre famille politique forcément évolué
et jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui le patron la droite c'est
laurent wauquiez qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein de votre copain
denis coderre mois à comment dire
apporter mon soutien justement j'allais
dire quel est votre rapport à vous à
laurent wauquiez on sait que aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que sa principale son
principal opposant c'est valérie
pécresse qui est aussi des yvelines vous
entre les deux vous avez en tout cas
fait votre votre choix je pense oui
clairement clairement je pense surtout
que
pardonnez moi puisque je suis un média
mais la construction médiatique fait que
l'on recherche beaucoup plus ce que
peuvent être les sujets d'acrimonie les
sujets de différences plutôt que de
rentrer au fond 2 face au fond d'eux des
projets des idées qui sont portés et
également d'essayer d'en faire de la
pédagogie auprès du grand public
quand on revient sur les élections
présidentielles c'est pitoyable
c'est pitoyable qui sa rivale par les
avons pas parlé des projets pendant tout
le pendant tout ce premier tour
bon tout ce premier tour on a cherché à
savoir comment les gens vivaient combien
gagnait et quelles étaient leurs
relations personnelles les cheveux et je
suis pas plus grossier que ça les
affaires ça toujours été ça toujours
existé dans toutes les campagnes
présidentielles c'est pas nouveau c'est
peut-être l'effet médiatique qui rend
cela encore plus important il ya
toujours eu des affaires là l'importance
que les médias accordent font que ça
fait caisse de résonance c'est tout mais
franchement qu'est ce qu'on tire de ce
premier tour
quels sont les engagements les grandes
lignes politiques qu'on a interrogé les
gens dans la rue et le vote du 2ème tour
est un vote par défaut c'est tout vous
faites partie de cette droite vous très
très critique envers emmanuel macron pas
question pour vous d'être constructif ou
alors s'il ya des bons projets de loi
des bonnes intentions vous êtes prêts à
les soutenir à l'assemblée nationale
mais j'ai toujours dit et je les ai même
écrit dans mon programme que je
privilégierai mon pays à voir mon parti
s'il ya des choses qui sont pertinentes
qui sont proposés je l'évoquerai vous
n'êtes pas constructif pour autant
absolument pas d'abord je ne sais pas ce
que c'est qu'être constructif comme si
les ai pas tous pour comme ça existe
comme si les autres ne l'étaient pas non
c'est
soit c'est de la vanité par rapport au
nom soit c'est simplement pour se faire
un peu valoir et puis faire que comme ça
on puisse aller chercher quelques postes
mais la réalité c'est que j'ai déjà voté
par exemple j'ai mode et les ordonnances
des ordonnances sur le travail même si
elle ne me satisfaisait pas sur leur
globalité
j'ai trouvé c'était une avancée qui
était important et je préfère plutôt que
dans une situation de blocage dogmatique
le dire mais si c'est une première
marche
eh bien il restera du temps pour pouvoir
monter les suivantes alors la république
en marche et c'est plutôt bien implanté
quand même dans le département on ce
député sur 12
vous êtes entre guillemets le seul
survivant et l'air est ce que ça vous
confère quand même une seule jusqu'à
survivants puisque je n'étais pas
sortant c'est vrai c'est vrai donc vous
êtes on va être l'exception et l'air est
ce que est ce que ça vous met une
pression particulière vous avez
l'impression d'être un peu plus scrutés
que plus d'autres puisque dans le
département il y aura ce que vous entre
guillemets alors bien sûr il ya les
conseillers départementaux
il ya les sénateurs mais à terre ça se
voyait beaucoup on connaît beaucoup ces
députés beaucoup plus que ces sénateurs
est ce que ça vous confère une pression
particulière ou ou non seul envoi
ou alors je vis bien l'impression mais
somme ça ne pose pas de pression et de
problème particulier
parfois c'est vrai que on peut se sentir
un petit peu seul lorsqu'il peut y avoir
des projets de territoire qui serait
intéressant de pousser ensemble mais bon
alors la vague en marche que vous
évoquez c'est pas une vague assis sur la
notoriété c'est pas une une vague qui a
été assise sur une légitimité de
compétences des intéressés par rapport à
ce qu'ils auraient pu mener et comme
action dans le passé puisqu'il n'en
n'ont pas mené pour terminer cette
émission il fallait avancer avec du
basket
on va terminer avec du basket une
question est-ce que vous l'ancien jeu
voir l'ancien président de club est ce
que vous connaissez le nouveau nom de la
ligue professionnelle française de
basket
on ne dit plus pro a désormais ce que
vous savez ce qu'on dit et bien écoutez
non parcellaire jp liszt et du naming
ça permet de faire rentrer de l'argent
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez en quelques
secondes de ce ce n'est ni aussi le
football qui a sa désormais écouter vous
voyez vous regrettez vous allez comme
quoi les activités de député des fois
éloigné un petit point des précisions
sportive
il y en a qui critiquent beaucoup moins
ce genre d'initiative
écoutez moi ce que je pense c'est que ce
qui est important c'est que le sport
soit valorisée qu'on sache vraiment de
quoi est-ce qu'on cause si vraiment tout
le monde s'y retrouve et que ça permet
peut-être d'apporter un petit peu plus
de fonds privés sur le sait le but je
pense que c'est une excellente chose
parce que on a besoin pour fonctionner
d'avoir des mets des moyens l'argent
public étant de plus en plus rares et
puis l'absence de sérieux de bonne
gestion d'un gouvernement qui ne sort
qui ne réforme pas l'état et qui
continue à augmenter la dette fait que
je pense que l'argent sera toujours de
plus en plus rares donc autant essayer
tout de suite d'aller le capter chez les
privés
merci michel vialay d'avoir participé à
ce café politique je rappelle que vous
êtes député les républicains de la 8e
circonscription des yvelines
c'est à dire le mantois le montage à
autour de mantes la jolie c'est noté
prochain numéro du café politique
vendredi
prochain à 20h30
[Musique]